>>
Hello, welcome. My name is Chris Tafay.
The Authors at Google speaker series is honored
to welcome author Greg Bear to Google Santa
Monica.
Greg Bear is the author of more than 30 books
of science fiction and fantasy, including
Quantico, Blood Music, the Forge of God, and
Darwin's Radio.
The recipient of two Hugo awards and five
Nebula awards, Bear's books cover topics as
diverse as galactic conflict, artificial universes,
networked intelligence, genetic engineering,
and nanotechnology.
In addition to being a prolific writer, Bear
has also served on political and scientific
action committees, advising Microsoft, the
U.S. Army, the CIA, Sandia National Laboratories,
and other groups and agencies in the course
of this rather remarkable career.
Please join me in welcoming Greg Bear as he
discusses his latest book, Mariposa.
>> [Applause]
Greg: Thanks for coming out here, and thanks
to all the people in the far flung corners
of the world here.
Mariposa is a follow-on to Quantico, which
had an interesting history which is nearly
legendary now.
As a science fiction writer, I thought I was
continuing to write science fiction, but some
of my editors suddenly realized I was moving
into technothrillers, and they didn't want
to do that.
And so, I was kind of caught betwixt and between
in a little bit of trouble.
Finally, it came out, and it turned out it
didn't matter.
People liked the book, and it was one of my
best selling books.
So publisher came back to me and said, "Let's
do another one."
And I think that living well is a dish best
served cold.
So we're on No. 2 of an impossible series
here, which -- and I still don't know, you
know, is technothriller or science fiction
-- I don't think there's much distinction.
Back when I was a kid, reading analog, John
W Campbell would publish stories that would
deal with, you know, new fighter aircrafts,
superfighter aircraft with a pilot jacked
into the control system working on a hallucinogenic
drug to heighten his sense of perception -- top
secret, superfast, over North Cape, crashes.
How do you get him out?
That's a Tom Clancy story.
But it was an analog science fiction.
So I grew up thinking that technothrillers
were science fiction.
I think Mariposa -- I'm actually moving into
another cycle here, which I was a little surprised
with.
When I finished Quantico, the book was published
in 2005, written between 2003 and 2004.
It describes a severe economic downturn in
the United States.
Well, that may or may not be prophesy, because
it was perfectly obvious to me that was coming.
In Mariposa, a couple of years down the road,
we're coming out of that, but we have major
difficulties.
And so, in coming so close to the future that
you actually live what you're writing about,
I think I need to listen to myself a little
more in terms of the stock market, which I
didn't.
Yah, I'm not supposed to be a prophet.
I don't think science fiction typically is
prophetic, but it does in this case -- I think,
when we get that close to the present, we
need to be really kind of politically sensitive
and organically sensitive.
I regard politics as biology.
And that biology can be predicted if you think
of trends, of personalities, of countries
that have personalities, of psychological
profiles -- think of a nation having a psychlogical
profile.
So maybe I'm a profiler of our country.
And in Mariposa, what I'm profiling is a major
security problem.
Our security problem is that we put ourself
in so much debt, perhaps $20 to $40 trillion
over the next ten years, that we owe our soul
to the company store.
Now, we've been pretty plush up until recent
times.
And so, our instincts aren't honed for that
particular difficulty, and our security instincts
really aren't honed for that at all.
We still think, you know -- despite the economic
downturn, we still believe that we're in charge
of our destiny.
But if you look at what's going on right now
with Clinton going to China and Obama going
to China.
They're not being very hard on China, why?
Because China owns us -- a substantial portion.
[pause]
So the upshot of all of this is that, in Mariposa,
we've got a major security problem with internal
sources.
That is, Axel Price is a CEO of a major corporation
in Texas, which provides government services
and training.
And that's been a real issue for me, because
I don't believe we should be outsourcing things
like prisons, military logistics and that
sort of thing.
Along the way, we're also dealing with the
situation that I had in Quantico -- the description
of our security problem as being not so much
from outside, which is the typical technothriller,
but from within. [pause]
I think the dictum that I follow -- ascribe
to most -- is Pogo's dictum, "We have met
the enemy and he is us."
And both Quantico and Mariposa are about our
eternal problems.
And we've really been our own worst enemies
since the beginning.
If you think of the worst war we ever fought,
it was with ourselves.
[coughing] Excuse me.
I've been fighting off a cold here.
The whole notion of our history being a kind
of a tangle of strong passions fighting up
against each other is fine as long as we're
stable, as long as we don't have severe imbalances.
But with this economic situation, what if
our internal enemies decide they want to reenact
something that's been supposedly gone for
150 years?
And that's the situation.
Now, in Quantico, my characters -- Rebecca
Rose, an FBI agent -- is now on furlough in
Mariposa.
She's looking to start a life -- to live a
life -- which she's never really had.
Because an FBI agent, as a female in a patriarchal,
male-oriented community, she's never been
able to really do that.
But she's on furlough, she started to set
up a family.
She's trying to adopt a girl.
And this is where things get interesting,
because I'm now going back full circle to
novels that I wrote in 1989, realizing the
political situations I was talking about in
1989 -- in a novel called Queen of Angels
-- are happening today.
The setup is perfect to just blend Mariposa
into the universe of Queen of Angels, which
is a universe in which you have computers
becoming 'competors' and eventually thinkers
-- in which you have, in 2047, everyone been
therapied.
Effective mental therapy gets rid of all of
our little foibles -- our mental foibles.
And in Mariposa, the Mariposa Treatment is
the very beginning of that therapy.
And it's a mixed bag, because it's brand new.
Mariposa takes away all the stops, all the
epigenetic learning that you've been through
as a biological organism.
PTSD, a major problem of today's world, is
simply being treated by Mariposa.
Mariposa starts off as a chemistry.
What is cancer? Cancer is tissue learning
bad habits.
Cancer is tissue that has been removed or
it's basically had the stops removed from
its destiny and becomes immortal or wants
to be immortal.
And those are epogenetic stops that's clamped
on DNA -- on genes.
You put a clamp on a gene, and that's the
epogenetic information on top of the sequence
of the gene.
And this is just as important in the body,
but also in your personality, in your psychology.
Because, as you go through life, the stress
built up on you, puts clamps on certain genes.
You start to, from birth, organize yourself
to fit into the environment which you're in.
And if you're in a battle situation or a law
enforcement situation with high stress or
violence or anything else, after a while,
you become locked into a rut of behaviors.
And those behaviors [inaudible]
Now, the whole sequence of Mariposa is that,
in treating cancer, our mad doctor has discovered
that you can also stop emotional problems.
But in removing the stops of the emotional
problems, it turns out you're also taking
away the stops of socialization.
So there's an element of Dr. Jekyll and Mr.
Hyde.
You become a Tabula rasa -- a newborn baby
with adult emotions and information.
The upshot of it all is that Mariposa works
sometimes.
But, in this novel, it's just the beginning.
And the opening chapter is the vice president
murders his wife.
We have an undercover agent working in Texas
from the FBI.
And then, we have a security conference in
the Los Angeles Convention Center that goes
badly wrong.
But, in that security conference, you get
to look at all of the concerns, the emotions,
and the technology of the present day taken,
say, humpty umpty years down the road -- just
a few years down.
The whole notion of 24-hour surveillance and
4K video is just down the road.
We can have it.
We can put the glasses on and have our lives
completely recorded in 4K video -- better
than HD.
You can have your car set up so that it feeds
video to the police if someone's tailgating
you.
In other words, you have a society with no
lubrication allowed whatsoever, because everything
can be caught on camera.
The cops can't misbehave badly.
You can't speed. You can't irritate people.
You can't do any of that, because if you do,
they'll get you.
So the whole idea of freedom becomes less
and less tolerant as we move on.
Now, the combination of all of these elements
leads to a science fiction scenario.
And so, I think that technothrillers and science
fiction are pretty much the same.
Politically, when I wrote Quantico, I thought
it was a liberal spree.
I thought that I was really coming down hard
on the kind of bad rule that we're facing:
Putting heavy duty stress on our law enforcement
people, on our soldiers, on our army, military.
Turned out that conservative websites gave
it good reviews and thumbs up, because they
thought it was fair and balanced.
I must have been doing something wrong.
In Mariposa, it's equally fair and balanced.
That is, it's another liberal's greed.
And the whole message behind it is, Bad Kings
Kill the land .
If you choose bad leadership -- if you choose
not wisely as to who is going to control you
-- you face the consequences.
And we are, in Mariposa, facing the consequences
-- still -- of those years in which we sold
our soul to the company store.
And we're still facing that, and we will for
years to come.
If America could be put into receivership
financially, what are we going to sell off
first?
The national parks? The military system?
Already we've sold off military training and
logistics to private companies.
What's the next step?
So that's the future I'm looking at.
The upside is, this is a hopeful book.
None of my books have been dystopias.
They're talking about people having a hell
of a hard time -- but surviving.
And at the end of my novel, my characters
all survive.
They're all doing well -- except for one thing,
they're completely liberated.
You have two main characters, Rebecca Rose
and my computer programmer, Nathaniel Trace,
who has been working on a 'competor,' Bob
Jones.
Does anybody recognize what I'm paying homage
to here -- a worldwide computer system that
could control the financial system?
It's Bloss Systems, written by D.S. Jones.
Nathaniel Trace and Rebecca have one thing
in common.
They are free of social concern.
Whether they be Dr. Jekyll or they be Mr.
Hyde, we don't know, but for them, the world
is completely fresh and new.
And so, I'd like to go on in the next book
to describe that world that they see with
completely fresh eyes.
I'm not sure where the politics are here or
the technology or where the genre, boundaries.
I don't see any of these things as dividing
or stopping me from moving into one territory.
But I do know that, in Mariposa, we are now
heading into that land of Queen of Angels.
And, in fact, in this book, you'll meet the
main character of Queen of Angels, which is
set in 2047, police detective named Mary Choi.
In this novel, she's ____.
So we're neatly tying it in.
And of course, Queen of Angels leads into
Movie Mars, Heads, and Omni Computing and
all. [mumbling]
I'm having great fun with the book.
It's kind of fun to go back and not mash it
together, though, they say robots and empires,
but to find that it really does go close to
the politics I was describing, it appears
I was working against in the 1980s are still
with me.
We haven't solved anything.
These are 30-year-old problems.
So that's where I'm at with this book.
I've got a lot of technological details in
here -- biological and programming lines and.
[mumbling] Can I answer any questions?
Yeah, any questions from out there in the
vast ether too.
>> [pause]
Q Do we need to read the Quantico first before
we read this one?
A Not really. You'll probably enjoy it if
you do, but in this one, the plot of Quantico
is kind of a reveal.
It's a background that's eventually kind of
creates suspense until you know what actually
happened.
So I've very cleverly set it up so that if
you don't read the novel -- but you will get
more information.
Q So in the books, you seem to present technology
-- enabling abilities of technology -- as
sort of a risky, but ultimately beneficial,
and capable of handling the issues.
I'm curious as to what you really believe
the chances of technology at solving some
of these other very real problems, such as
debt and things like that.
A National debt?
Q As a stand-in for very big problems that
we all have?
A
The national debt, of course, is kind of a
psychological, monetary, hormonal problem;
isn't it?
I mean, money is permission to get working.
And the way it's manipulated and hypermanipulated
and metamanipulated around the world is very
tough to understand except from a biological
perspective.
It's like a brain trying to find blood sugar.
And every so often, it'd have an epileptic
seizure.
And the blood sugar is allocated in the incorrect
ways -- goes to the incorrect areas to solve
problems.
I think that's what happens when the economy
gets filtered.
We lose the ability to connect between the
symbolic value of money and the ability to
get work done.
So you have things that are hypervalued, but
really aren't.
And suddenly, people find themselves with
less incentive to do work than they thought
they had, and they slow down.
They get depressed.
How's that not like an organism with blood
flow and all of that?
So solving that problem is more of a psychological
problem than a technological one.
And that's really interesting.
You could set all the economics in the world
to zero if everyone agreed to.
And just start over again and say, "Okay,
you know."
And they've done this in countries that had
hyperinflation.
Set it all back to zero.
Basically reorient, re-naturalize, re-normalize,
like quantum mechanics -- if it doesn't work,
normalize it.
And that's an interesting idea.
Other larger problems.
Therapy, in Queen of Angels, was designed
to remove the last of our medieval variations.
You know, if you take a look at a medieval
painting or Renaissance painting and look
at all these characters with moles and warts
and noses and distortions and hunchbacks and
everything.
We watch the Dutch masters painting their
towns and their cities.
We realize that today, physically, we're probably
better off than them, but mentally, we still
have all those warts and all of those bends
and problems.
Get rid of those, and what do we have?
A different society.
In Mariposa, we're coming to grips with the
early stages of that.
What do we want to be?
How do we want to define ourselves?
How do we want our personal interactions to
build?
How efficient do we want to be?
How sane do we want to be?
I mean, again, this notion that we get socialized
by clamping down various genes -- acquire
an epogenetic veneer -- as we get older, is
probably one hundred percent accurate.
That's probably what happens to us.
And PTSD, under those conditions, is learning
bad habits, which work well on the battlefield
or in crime situations or in violent situations,
but work very poorly when you're at home in
bed trying to sleep.
All of these things, then, come back to what
is our evolution and metaevolution and how
do we want to direct ourselves, and again
[mumbling] The question -- of whether it'll
work or not -- is irrelevant, because of course,
sometimes it'll work and sometimes it won't,
just like all the technology we use.
Technology is a human endeavor.
Not doing it is not an issue.
We can't stop ourselves from doing it, because
we always offer that carrot at the end of
the stick, "Okay, things are going to be better."
Q My question was more to, What do you actually
believe about, you know, the likelihood of
beneficial outcomes in the future?
A You have it happen all the time.
I mean, would you go back to 1924?
Q Twenty-four sounds bad, no. [laughter]
A What would you go back to?
Q If I could get stock in the, well no, '24
wasn't that bad.
It was '29 that was bad, so.
A Those five years you could have fun.
Q Exactly.
A You can sell real estate for five more years.
Q Just keep looping.
A Yep.
Q No, I guess it was more like, Do you actually
see the future as being that bright, given
the -- obviously, technology has gotten us
this far.
And there are issues, but it seems overall
to be a benefit.
As a futurist, what do you see in the near
future?
A What concerns me most right now is, I don't
think most people believe there is a future.
They don't see any difference or change that
will benefit them.
And they're afraid nearly all of the time.
And so, they go back to the more cozy stuff,
which is the more acceptable stuff about zombies
and vampires.
These are monsters they know.
The future is a monster they don't know.
And what do they do?
They romanticize zombies and vampires.
I mean, pretty soon, we're going to have zombie
babysitters, if we don't have them already.
Kids -- it's going to be like the Frankenstein's
monster.
It isn't scary anymore.
So, we've taken our old monsters and normalized
them, and our new monster is the future.
And we don't want to know what it is, because
we don't know what we want to be.
We just don't.
America is at a crossroads now.
What do you all want to do?
Do we want to go back to a Golden Age that
never existed?
Do we want to move ahead to a liberal view
of the world that never worked before?
We just don't know.
We don't know how to handle our finances,
how to handle our freedom, our equalities.
And yet, somehow, America always stumbles
along.
We've been in worse situations. So yeah, I'm
optimistic.
But think about it, we have been in much worse
situations, where our passions have produced
extraordinary violence.
And Mariposa is about avoiding that, about
not allowing people to have their worst passions
rule the world.
Along the way, that means of course, you got
to kick some butt and bring out some pole
axes and all that sort of stuff.
Q So I got a question.
So it seems to me that Axel Price's company
is very similar to maybe another company that
you might have modeled it on?
A Several different companies.
Q Yeah, I mean, it's an amalgamation, but
the one that stood out for me was Blackwater
and even the name is similar to the owner
there.
And yeah, and so.
A It does sounds like a bomb-building prison.
Q Yeah, it does. It does. So?
A Jonathan Price.
Q So, the Blackwater comparison was clear
to me, but since it's an amalgamation, what
other companies out there is this -- I guess,
it's sort of -- dystopian corporation that
you're kind of modeling?
A Well, you know, I'm thinking of -- all of
the service companies that provide services
for Washington, D.C.
-- and full disclosure, I've received checks
from many of them for attending ___ conferences
and so on.
There'd be KBR, Kellogg, Brown, Route.
These companies have always been very helpful
in Washington, D.C. in setting up conferences,
in providing logistic support, and all sorts
of support activity.
Where I find them to be less than useful is
when they're allowed to kill people without
consequences.
Soldiers aren't. And that seems dysfunctional
to me.
Or when we're going to sell off 'death row'
to a private company.
That I don't want to see.
That I think is going much too far, the privatization
of security and our armed forces is not a
good idea.
One, because an army is beholden to the civilians
that pay for it.
And if you have a firewall between payment,
punishment, and performance, and someone can
get away with not delivering on their contractual
obligations, or violates those contractual
obligations, or is never given any obligations
under the contract, except vague ones, doesn't
work for me.
America is about Americans controlling their
firepower.
It's not about removing your sense of guilt
or responsibility by assigning it to somebody
else that you can say it was their fault.
We should be guilty.
Q Does assigning it to someone else sort of
open up freedom for Americans in a sense?
A How will that be?
Q Well, you have freedom if you don't have
to think about those things, right?
A Yeah, you have freedom of guilt, but if
you're guilt-free, you're dysfunctional.
You need to be therapied at that one. [laughter]
Mariposa is for you. No guilt, no glory.
But yeah, I think that that would be one of
the reasons people might want to give this
up is, they want to live in their BMW, buy
their BMW, have their home theater, and never
leave the house, because you don't want to
pay taxes to -- you don't want to build community.
Don't be responsible for community or for
country.
Patriotism without responsibility or without
a sense of country seems to me to be kind
of a loose cannon.
You have a question?
Oh, collating -- still collating.
Yeah. Oh, whichever one want to go first,
sure.
San Francisco. All right.
Q Sort of, you have a great breadth of knowledge
and even depth into the research here.
I was wondering if you could sort of go into
what comes first -- your plot or your research?
Do you go and read a whole bunch of different
things, and then, file them away as sort of,
"Oh, I could use this at some point in the
future."
Or do you weave your plot, and then, sort
of go and do deep dives into finding out the
specifics on the technologies?
A You know, yes on all accounts.
I've been privileged to be kind of at the
birthry of a lot of these activities in government.
So in a sense, 9/11, but even before then,
by being in consultation with Sandia, NASA,
and NASA administrators working on the Citizens
Advisory Committee through the '80s and '90s.
Seeing not only how government works, but
also how the personalities interact of what
people who have been in government.
Let's say, the whole cold warriors talk about
the Cold War days -- utterly chilling.
You know, thank God that went away.
But it went away with surprising speed, because
the first meeting I had with the Citizens
Advisory Counsel was in 1983, Star Wars defense
was proposed that same year, Soviet Union
started to collapse in 1981.
And we could see that there were severe problems,
but the reports from the military were that
the problems were going to get worse and worse
and worse and eventually computers will be
controlling the situation.
So, that basically inspired me to write Eon,
realizing all of those situations and the
personalities and the technologies.
I had to figure out, What happens if something
comes in and interferes?
The old story in science fiction was, aliens
would unite us.
What if an alien opportunity comes in and
divides us to the point of driving us to war?
Like, you know -- I don't know -- a solid
gold meteor landing in the middle of a primitive
village.
What would you do with it?
So yeah, it's a little of both -- all of those
things together.
And then, later on, coming into Homeland Security,
talking at the FBI Academy in Quantico, talking
to agents, putting their personalities in
place.
The stories come later in that case, but some
of the research is already there.
The impetus.
You had a question, sir.
Q So, this is a frequently asked question,
but How would you recommend getting into writing?
You know, it's a nano Rhymo?
A You have to write.
You know, in your copious spare time.
I don't know how many hours you work here
-- a lot, I suspect.
But in your copious spare time, you have to
set aside an hour a day or in the morning
before you come in.
I know my friend, Joe Haldeman, used to get
up very early in the morning and write and
then go off and ride a bike and all that sort
of stuff for exercise.
Yeah. One hour a day, put aside, make sure
your family and your work don't interfere
with -- and write.
And if you write a page a day, you have a
novel at the end.
Second clue, don't be afraid.
You don't have to show it to anybody.
Maybe no one will ever see it.
But then you write, it's your own personal
thing.
You try it out. You have fun with it. You
relax.
And the zen of relaxing is the most important
thing.
If nobody ever has to see it, you're free.
But if at some point, you come along and say,
"Well, this is pretty good."
Then, you can hand it out to sympathetic friends
and relatives.
If you don't have people who are supportive,
don't hand it out.
Just send it straight off to the editor, because
if you're going to be rejected, you might
as well be rejected by a stranger.
Yeah, that's the way to go.
Any other thoughts about writing?
What are you working on?
Q Kind of a future history thing.
A That's where we all get started.
One of my first ideas as a kid was, "Let's
write this future history going out to billions
of years of history."
It's great fun. Ended up in City at the End
of Time.
Q Oh, I'm not going that far. A few decades.
A No, yeah, exercising and modeling and playing
with ideas.
It's all great fun.
There's no reason you can't just continue
to be fun.
But also, if you actually get something good,
who knows?
Other questions? Yes.
Q One of the things you were talking about
was how the technology is -- to intentionally
misparaphrase you -- you were saying how people
are enjoying staying home and using their
widescreen TV and avoiding the inconvenience
of going out and noticing that there is a
city out there.
In many ways, this is sort of a culture variant
back to when the city out there was the culture,
because there wasn't much culture you could
get at home.
So, I suspect what's happened is the economies
of scale have made it feasible to create a
culture, which is physically nonlocal.
But that's driven out of the economy of scale
with that sort of cheaper to deliver to people
on average than trying to deliver it in a
city.
Do you see any opportunity for -- it's easy
to say 'technology' -- I meant more technology
in a sense of the opportunities for the society
_____ technology whether technology will remove
those economies of scale that's driving the
culture away from the cities and essentially
make those same communities still there, but
they're smaller, so that they -- and you're
only localizing them.
A We certainly see that in the notion of small,
suburban, apartment buildings and malls.
Well, your shops are nearby.
But I find those areas rather boring.
What you want is the unexpected, but what
Americans seem to have been trying to go for
for the last 20 years is "Only the expected,
thank you."
No surprises, I want to pay for a uniformity
of excellence with no surprises.
We see it in our retailing, in our entertainment
industry.
We are really -- as we try to force ourselves
to be more and more uniform.
At the same time, we want to be more and more
prosperous.
When in fact, it seems to me that the most
prosperous and successful person out there
is the one who's constantly surrounded by
good surprises.
You can't generate that by having a controlled
environment.
In a city, a well-ruled city is full of lovely,
strained, and sometimes awkward surprises.
And that's what makes a biography.
My friend Larry Nevin says, "I've got enough
money.
I just don't have enough memories."
I think that's a beautiful philosophy.
And memories are not made by uniformity or
expected expectations that are fulfilled.
They are made by surprises.
Any other.
As long as not too much surprise.
Surprise heading over into technothriller
shock, I'd like to avoid too.
But on the other hand, I simply like to read
about it, so.
Q Okay, another question.
So I was fascinated by your statement that
you felt that your Quantico novel was kind
of a leftist screed in a sense.
I can see the sort of -- what people traditionally
sort of think of as left-oriented themes in
Mariposa -- I haven't read Quantico -- but
what would you say are the right-leaning themes
that you think your readers have sort of grasped
on to?
A Well, actually, I think it's the characters
have their own politics.
I don't impose my politics on the characters.
Most of my law enforcement characters are,
in fact, conservative.
Even Rebecca Rose is very kind of hard-bitten
law enforcement.
And I think that appeals to people rather
than having views imposed on psychologies.
So I think that's what they're getting.
They're getting an honesty of the depiction
of the reaction of the characters.
As to whether the situation in Mariposa is
leftist or not, it certainly criticizes prior
administrations.
But at this point, the president in Mariposa
is a Democrat and she still faces incredible
difficulties.
And some of them, you know, come from missteps
in her own administration.
A lot of them come from the past.
But that's with all presidencies.
Q So what would be like a left view of the
government or a right view of government sort
of through the eyes of the characters in Mariposa?
A I think it'd be more the realization that
history still ruled, the passions of history
still ruled.
And I don't think conservatives would feel
at all comfortable with that notion.
When we have Axel Price at the end of the
book -- I won't spoil too much -- spouting
off his philosophy of life, it is I think,
you know, a philosophy that many conservatives
would find very appealing.
And yet, at the same time, you realize he's
trying to destroy our nation.
Why?
Why would he want to do that?
What is he reenacting here?
Well, he's reenacting a passion of 50 years
ago.
A resentment that's built up for over centuries.
And that's something we usually ascribe to
the Middle East.
We often say, "The Middle East is a place
where history goes to die."
They all hate each other.
Well, what's going on here? Same thing.
So I think that that would be considered to
be -- I think some conservatives would resent
that assertion.
Part of their philosophy is Confederate.
On the other hand, the liberals will take
no comfort from this book, as I'm saying basically,
"We all have to work together here."
Not all of the country that's conservative
is going to go along with my Bond Billan's
attitudes.
Who knows what's going to draw us all back
together again?
But we do need to do that.
We do need to come together.
And it's possible that this financial situation
we're entering will be the equivalent of World
War II forcing us to do that.
We have a decision to make.
Are we going to finance our own country, or
are we going to watch it go down the drain
-- be owned by foreigners?
It's a big decision.
>> Any other questions from D.C.? No? Okay.
Thank you very much.
A My pleasure.
Thank you.
>> [Applause]